by this
[Music]
welcome to another exciting episode of
kos
and today i bring you the second part of
my
phoenix saga i'm not gonna give you the
whole story on her
because there might be other statues
that i get to tell another story about
but i'm going to give you my take on a
fight that show guys
probably didn't even look at too deeply
and overlook the situation today i bring
you
xm studios dark phoenix
an incredible statue but we're going to
get into the particulars on this statue
in a few minutes
let's just dig into the story that
brought
this character into
the x-men life now
at this point in time jean grey has
already
uh absorbed the phoenix force into
her body and she popped out the ocean we
went through that
look at the first video from kos
with the og xm studio stature
uh but now i'm going to talk about a
character
that's not very well known and
was very integral to this character
being developed
we're going to talk about mastermind
mastermind is a massive illusions
and what he does is his mutant powers he
can
uh make illusions that feel real sound
real
tastes real smell real he's like
mysterio without the gadget see mysterio
has no powers he does
all that with technology mastermind
does it all by his mutant ability
now mastermind is a
very unattractive looking man to say the
least
but what he did in his illusions he
seduced jean grey
so what he would do is he would pop up
at every
space that she was at and he would
seduce her into thinking that they were
long lost loves
and it would be this victorian scene
he's part
of the hellfire club and the hellfire
club
led by sebastian shaw
is a group of mutants that are the elite
of the league they're one of my favorite
group of mutants
evil mutants next to the brotherhood of
evil mutants
so at this point in time he has seduced
her
into thinking that she is with him
and she becomes the black queen for the
hellfire
club just like emma frost is the white
queen it had the black queen
it's like chess pieces and she
was under the illusion jean grey was
under the illusion of mastermind
cyclops was going crazy they had
captured some of the x-men
wolverine had broke free and actually
broke
back into the hellfire club to save the
love of his life
now unbeknownst to mastermind
jean grey has the phoenix force inside
and she's fighting the phoenix force
while fighting his illusions
we didn't know emma frost had gave
uh a psionic dampener device
to mastermind to amplify the dampening
so jane grey couldn't scan his mind
battling with the dark phoenix the dark
phoenix busts
out and in this battle that she's having
with mastermind she just touches his
mind and gives him cosmic awareness
and turns him into a blithering idiot
leaning up against the wall and this is
when we get
dark phoenix costume turns red
and gold from the green and gold and she
is a full
fully realized entity and
this is when the cosmic comic books
start
for the x-men she's the jumping off
point
probably one of the best known stories
an incredible read
i suggest you go back read these books
the phoenix saga so you can know more
about this character
well let's get into the statue well
we're going to start with the base
the base is done
in a resin and and
and it is a polystone resin it is
beautiful
in how they have the flames going up and
the flames is twisting all over if you
look at my ghost rider video
the flames are very similar with the
rock
and it looks like brimstone down at the
bottom and it
forms the phoenix in back of her
and you can see jean grey's face with
her hair
all lit up and it comes with three
different portraits
the three different portraits are
one without fire with a normal face the
next one
with a face like she's using her powers
without the flame here i will be
displaying her
with the flame here because i think it
engulfs
exactly what the statue is trying to do
she has a fire in her hand the fire is
wrapping around her
she is fully the phoenix force
now she is no longer jean grey she's 100
the phoenix force
and i love this statue for that
depiction
well this is the part in the video when
i'm going to ask you to
like follow subscribe and hit that join
button
hit that joy button you know where that
join button is
it's right there down at the bottom hit
that join button so you can follow the
realm
and also get notifications when getting
your new kos is up
kos is doing great things iron lords is
doing great things go to lords of
gaming.net
where we have ton of e3 stuff happening
right now
we have a ton of opinion writers and we
have
the weeks where we do uh five seconds
with your lord
and you actually get a chance to get
more insights
of you know what you want to know about
with the lords little personal stuff
maybe sometimes
you get real funny jokes um also check
out
law cognito's the last word destiny and
outriders is doing incredible things
right now
so go to the last word with lord cognito
and ibontes where you can see
all that loudest shooter stuff and learn
more about the new metas and what guns
are good and what guns aren't
seeing next week when i get a chance to
go into another cosmic entity she took
us to space
why not go to some place
where we can surf around
stay collecting
[Laughter]
[Music]
late night it's been a long flight
stayed on
strange
[Music]
felt like the millionth time
reconnection
from several sections cause we could
meet in the middle with no sense of
direction
if it's sun up to sundown we mess around
we're way too involved now
i never
[Music]
i never wanted someone to take control
i'll let you take control i let you in
too
close so baby just go go
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
but now it's hard to mention i don't
feel
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
now baby just go go
[Music]
i never wanted someone to disappear
to disappear to just get out
[Music]
i let you take control
[Music]